escribe 645 millones 584 mil 462 de
manera estándar vamos por partes tenemos
645 millones 645 millones pero no queda
ahí estos 600 45 millones lo podemos ver
como que lo multiplicamos esta cantidad
por un millón
un millón así que esto es igual a 645
seguido de seis ceros 1 2 3 4 5 6 bueno
veamos la siguiente parte 584.000 es
584.000 que es esta cantidad
multiplicada por mil que es igual a 584
seguido de 30 123 y le ponemos comas
para separar igual aquí arriba para que
sea fácil leer
ahora la última parte 462 bueno éste no
está multiplicado por nada es tal cual
la cantidad 462 que es igual a esta
misma cantidad 462 ahora vamos a tomarlo
todo lo voy a escribir de este lado son
645 millones + 584.000 mas 462
qué nos queda aquí regreso el código de
colores originales 645 millones 584 mil
462 esta es la cantidad que me piden
aquí como bien analizamos paso a paso
pero con la práctica podemos hacer esta
suma mucho más rápido de forma mental
podemos pensar en que tenemos 600 45
millones que tiene 6 ceros a la derecha
584 tendrá 3 ceros a la derecha y 462 no
tiene ceros a la derecha quedando así
645 millones pero yo tengo en mente que
aquí hay 6 lugares después sigue el 584
midi y aquí en la mente tengo que hay
tres lugares a la derecha de este número
y finalmente escribo 462 que llena los
tres lugares que había y a su vez estos
llenan los seis lugares que había a la
derecha de esta cantidad si aquí hubiera
sido que 284 mil y nada más pues aquí
hubiera puesto tres ceros